Sarah Wagenknecht und die Linke das ist
die Geschichte einer kaum aufzuhaltenden
zerruto sie hat angekündigt nicht mehr
für die Partei zu kandidieren und denkt
im Interview mit uns offen über die
Gründung einer eigenen Partei nach was
also hält sie eigentlich noch ab
ein solches Projekt zu beginnen wenn man
nicht wichtige Voraussetzungen
gewährleisten kann das sollte man nicht
machen also ich möchte schon wenn man
nicht meine politische Laufbahn mit
einem Flop abschließen
Wagenknecht hadert
öffentlichkeitswirksam
Gregor Gysi kennt Sahra Wagenknecht seit
vielen Jahren er hat 2007 die PDS mit
der westdeutschen spd-abspaltung wer es
geht zur Linken zusammengeführt sein
Lebenswerk Gysi will nicht an den Erfolg
einer Wagenknecht Partei glauben dann
hat sie drei Monate lang einen Buben und
dann geht das wieder Berg ab etc und
dann entsteht ja eine echte
Konkurrenzsituation als erleben braucht
man auch 16 Landesverbände man braucht
mindestens 20 Büros das muss auch alles
bezahlt werden das klingt alles so
einfach ist aber schwierig und was wenn
Sie vorhandene Strukturen nutzt der
ehemalige
CDU-Bundestagsabgeordnete und
Medienmanager jürgen Todenhöfer hat 2020
eine eigene Partei gegründet
teamtodenhöfer unter wagenknechts
umstritten im friedensaufruf steht sein
Name es gibt Spekulationen Wagenknecht
könnte sich mit seiner kleinen Partei
zusammen tun
zu einer Spekulation die mich betrifft
sage ich gar nichts aber es gibt in
Deutschland mehrere junge Parteien die
die Erfahrung einer Gründung hinter sich
haben und die Sarah Wagen nicht mit
offenen Armen aufnehmen würden laut
Umfragen hätte Wagenknecht ein
zweistelliges Wählerpotenzial vor allem
bei der Anhängerschaft von AFD der
linken und in Ostdeutschland aber Wähler
Potenzial ist nicht gleich Wahlergebnis
es ist wohl noch immer die Hoffnung von
Fraktionschef Bartsch das Wagenknecht
das Wagnis nicht eingeht Bartsch setzt
auf weiter so es sichert seine macht er
will sie wieder zu einem Zitat wichtigen
Bezugspunkt machen das ist für mich eine
Normalität dass alle Mitglieder der
Fraktion eingebunden werden müssen und
da
ja wirke ich darauf hin dass das auch
bei Sahra Wagenknecht durchaus mehr
passiert als jetzt ich habe mit Dietmar
Bartsch immer gut zusammengearbeitet und
natürlich hoffe ich dass ich auch
überschaubarer Zeit auch wieder im
Parlament reden kann aber
wir haben ja natürlich die Entwicklung
im Parteivorstand die ja deutlich anders
ist als das was die Fraktionsspitze
vertritt seit September entscheidet die
fraktionsversammlung ob Wagenknecht im
Parlament sprechen darf Gregor Gysi
drängt Wagenknecht jetzt zu einer
schnellen Entscheidung
jetzt so wild entschlossen ist eine neue
Partei aufzubauen ich bin nicht sicher
aber das schließt das gar nicht aus
letztlich entscheidet sie mit anderen
zusammen darüber und nicht ich nur eins
geht nicht dass wir uns Monate lang mit
dieser Frage beschäftigen und uns nicht
inhaltlich konzentrieren auf die Dinge
die notwendig sind
und
deshalb kann ich nur sagen wenn Leute
das Vorhaben dann sollen sie es schnell
machen sollen nicht die Partei ewig
quälen die historische Spaltung der
Linken irgendwann muss Sarah Wagenknecht
entscheiden ob Sie die will wann wird
sie entscheiden
also ich gehe davon aus dass innerhalb
des nächsten
Dreivierteljahres maximal ein Jahres die
Entscheidung so oder so fallen wird und
auch bekannt sein wird auf Twitter
reagiert die Parteispitze auf unser
Interview anzukündigen dass man im
Verlauf der nächsten Monate über die
Bildung einer konkurrierenden Partei
entscheiden will ist verantwortungslos
die Linke steht momentan wie das
Kaninchen vor der Schlange unklar ob die
Partei eine Spaltung überleben würde
Ausgang der Zerrüttung offen